le film s'intitule la canicule il est en
cours de tournage près d'orléans les
acteurs hier ont eu très chaud
un incendie a éclaté pendant le tournage
mais lee marvin fameux acteur américain
qui dans ce film d'yves boisset vous son
premier rôle français lee marvin est
sain et sauf
elisabeth est gelé les marvin a quitté
les grands espaces américains pour la
plaine de la beauce le temps du tournage
de la canicule dans le dernier film
d'yves boisset le héros de l'homme qui
tua liberty valance reste fidèle ou type
de rôles qui ont fait sa gloire il est
ici un gangster américain un gentil
méchant comme dans la plupart de ses
films il attendu d'avoir 60 ans pour
venir tourner en france
qu'est-ce qu'il a donc attiré alors il
ya un peu une légende autour du
personnage de lee marvin on dit entre
autres que vous dormez avec un flingue
pour votre oreiller ce que c'est vrai
dans ces films lee marvin et s'il tue
bourru lui avons demandé s'il était
aussi dans la vie
mais les deux dans la canicule le
dialogue et en deux langues pour donner
la réplique à ses partenaires ici victor
lanoux et jean carmet lee marvin
s'exprime en américain le dialogue
franco américain ne semble pas être une
difficulté pour les acteurs j'arrive à
bien m'entendre avec lui parce qu'il met
une certaine complaisance à s'exprimer
et se dire que par exemple comme team 18
ans le fun et c'est toujours mauvais
téléphone est comme ça somme minime
beaucoup une home beaucoup de bulles
seuls les acteurs une espèce de une
espèce de langue qui fait qu' on se
reconnaît un peu au rythme et s'il est
facile d'avoir des contacts avec lee
marvin en dehors du tournage tout à fait
on vit on vient ensemble carrément avec
victor
celle ci me paraît toujours un peu
taciturne un peu bourru et qu'il est
comme ça dans la vie courante mois kim
duk désastre se produit tout ça dans la
vie j'ai au contraire je crois mais on
en sait plus pêche de l'exorcisme des
mauvais sentiments